[Music]
welcome again to another episode of
what's up prof
i'm martin smith and this is walter
fight
how are you doing martin i'm well with
walter and you i'm fine
so today we're going back to babylon
yes
and then
the message has to swell into a loud cry
and then we'll go home
yes
now before we start again this is
a summation a summary of of events
and the purpose of bringing it in this
format
even though it has
been mentioned in many many previous
ones in pieces
is to have one
available
that can be handed out to
others who
might be able to
get an understanding of what babylon is
all about and what the loud cry is all
about so it's basically an evangelistic
tool right that's it yeah so for some
people it will be revision yes but it's
always good to have revision to sharpen
that mind to when you go out
yes you have your points in your ducks
in a row correct and we're getting to
the point where the loud cry is
beginning to swell
so people need to know
what it is about
and this one little package can be
downloaded
from the download server
and hand it out
that's it let's open with a word of
prayer
our father in heaven thank you very much
again for bringing us together
lord we again ask you to please
enlighten our minds bless the discussion
and help the viewers and us to spread
this like the leaves of autumn in jesus
name amen amen
so let us begin from the beginning
and
let us see
what does the bible mean when it talks
about babylon
and how does it relate to the old
testament
the beauty of the bible is
that it's never obsolete it's never an
old story because even the old story are
typological stories so they're always
very very important for the times that
we live in so you know that's so
interesting what you're saying because
since i started realizing this through
your lectures and other lectures
that this typology
if you read the bible
it it opens up so much more because you
draw it to your day and implement and
see how this is still relevant
today it's actually and every word you
know when the bible says
man does not live by bread alone but by
every word that proceeds out of the
mouth of the lord
and this is what frustrates me beyond
measure is when these modern
translations based on those
waste paper basket documents
leave out words because they think it's
unnecessary repetition
it's so ridiculous because it totally
destroys the harmony
but in any case we will sit with that
problem till the end so here's this
picture of
balsasa
sitting at his party and the writing
came upon the wall
and daniel was called to interpret it
and this is the writing that was written
many many tackle ufarsen
and this is the interpretation of the
thing many god has numbered thy kingdom
and finished it
tackle
thou weighed in the balances are not
found
wanting
peres
thy kingdom is divided and given to the
meads and the persians
now martin
why is many repeated
it's referring to two kings yes
there were two rulers
and balshasa was the one who was in
charge of the civil duties the
government as as it were
and his father
was the one who was interested in the
religious aspects and so he had
basically reclused himself
and was the religious head
and it's
important his father was not
nebuchadnezzar no no
no
so what we have here
is we have two manners and both of them
have been numbered
and found wanting
so many many
god has numbered thy kingdom and
finished it both in the civil sphere and
the religious sphere it's a union of
church and state
so it's very important that there is
this repetition that we find here
and this was the fall of literal babylon
and the bible says it will never be
rebuilt
never
and
it has never been rebuilt
actually the bible says it will never be
rebuilt and occupied so some portions
have been rebuilt
as museum
exhibits but there is
no
city of babylon
in the world today
so this is a very interesting
um basic starting point with the fall of
babylon
both aspects
fell
now if we go to revelation chapter 18
where it deals with the loud cry
and it says after these things i saw
another angel come down from heaven
having great power and the earth was
lightened with his glory
now angel is messenger and god always
works through his agents and through
humanity
so this
message with the power of the angel
behind it is a message that must go out
into the world
and we read and he cried mightily with a
strong voice saying babylon the great is
fallen
is fallen
and has become the habitation of devils
and the hold of every foul spirit in a
cage of every unclean and hateful bird
can you see that we have a repetition
there again martin
there are two things that have fallen
many many
fallen
fallen there were again two aspects
church craft
statecraft
and they are linked together in a unit
and they are
fallen
now
it's interesting martin when we
discussed this thing in the bible and i
was doing this series on hebrews that is
going out at the moment
and there again it became very clear
that the kingly duty and the priestly
duty were to be strictly
separated
and if a king crossed that boundary and
felt that he was a priest
then leprosy was the result right now
what is leprosy a symbol of sin sin
now do we have a individual on the
planet at the moment
who holds his himself to be a king
and also a priest
and therefore what clings to him
leprosy yes all
the sinfulness all the sentiment is
called the man of
sin
and there's only one that is both a king
and a priest
and he's both a horn a political power
and a woman a church
so
this is what is fallen babylon the great
is fallen it's fallen it's become a
habitation of devils
and the hold of every fowl spirit in the
cage of every unclean and hateful bird
now
a bird in the bible
can have many symbolic meanings
and the holy spirit is depicted as a
clean bird a dove
and
it's a very interesting symbol because
the dove is also a gentle
creature
so it's become a house of every unclean
and hateful bird and therefore we can
assume there's a false holy spirit
active in this system
and there are demonic activities going
on
and then the unfortunate news is that
all the nations have drunk of the wine
of the wrath of her fornication
so the nations have drunk in her
philosophy
and the kings of the earth have
committed fornication with her so the
political systems are united with her
that is an illicit union
church
and state
fallen
and the merchants of the earth are waxed
great through the abundance of her
delicacies so the economic world is it
also
embodied in the system definitely
this church state system yes correct
and i had another voice from heaven
saying come out of her my people that ye
be not partakers of her sins
and that you receive not of her plague
she's going to be punished
and god's people are aware according to
this verse
you know yes
so that's why they have to come out they
have to come up
for her sins have reached unto heaven
and god has remembered her iniquities
so if people read this verse
they will have to understand what sin is
so that we can identify
the system that we're talking about here
the bible is very clear that sin is the
transgression of the law
whosoever committeth sin transgresses
also the law for sin is the
transgression of the law 1 john 3 verse
4.
and james 2 verse 9 says if you respect
a person
you commit sin
and are convinced of the law
as transgressors
that's a very interesting spin on the
ball
basically what the bible is telling you
what sin is sin is the transgression of
the law what law god's law obviously
right the ten commandments
so this system is a sinful system that
transgresses god's law
the roman catholic church as we know has
not only transgressed god's law they've
changed it and therefore made sure that
everybody else transgresses that well
right
well they think they've changed they
think they've changed it but then it
says here if you
have respect to a person that that me
does that mean i may not respect certain
individuals or i may not have respect to
my parents or to whatever no
what this means
is if you pay attention and listen to
someone who takes you away from god's
law which is sin
then that is sin too yes even if it
looks like he is from god
correct so be careful that no one
deceives you right
so if you have respect to this person
this man of sin
then
you
become a sinner if you are compliant
to his wishes
so babylon is a transgressor of god's
law
revelation 18 verse 4 says and i heard
another voice from heaven saying come
out of her my people
because the world will be destroyed
because of sin
and god doesn't want you to be a
partaker of her sin so doesn't that mean
that he wants you to keep his law and
not their law yes okay
why
so that you can be saved and not receive
her plagues
verse 5 says and her sins have reached
unto heaven
and god has remembered her iniquities
it's just interesting for me once again
the law is being put into protection
is brought together so the law is there
to protect you correct we spoke about
the law of liberty remember it's a very
important aspect
so now that brings us to the point where
we can actually say who is babylon
revelation 16 verse 9 gives us more
clues and the great city was divided
into three parts so she also calls
herself a city
a city on seven hills
and she was divided into three parts
so babylon consists of three components
and the cities of the nations fell why
because they were complicit with them
and the great babylon came into
remembrance before god to give unto her
the cup of the wine of the fierceness of
his wrath
so it is also the great city that rules
over the nations
and it consists of three parts
and if we go to verse 13
we see that it is the one that is full
of unclean spirits like frogs
and they come out of three components so
we have the definition they come out of
the dragon component
and they come out of the mouth of the
beast
false prophet
now all three of those are identified in
the scripture
very clearly
and the reformers
made it absolutely clear that they
understood that the beast power was none
other than the roman system the roman
catholic system
and
it had unclean spirits in other words
the spirit by which they acted was not
the spirit of god it was a false spirit
because it was not in harmony with god's
law to the law and to the testimony if
they speak not in harmony with this word
there's no light in them
now who is the dragon
who is the beast and who is the false
prophet so let's just go through them
and let the bible answer
all right let's have a look who the
dragon is revelation 12 verse 9
and the great dragon was cast out that
old serpent called the devil and satan
which deceiveth the whole world he was
cast out into the earth and his angels
were cast out with him
so
this is demonic right this is
devilish and that's a component of
babylon so there must be
dogmas
and doctrines and teachings with which
the world is deceived that come directly
from the mouth of the serpent
part of babylon that's it
okay
john 8 verse 44 tells us you of your
father the devil and the lusts of your
father you will do he was a murderer
from the beginning and abode not in the
truth because there is no truth in him
when he speaks a lie he speaks of his
own he's a liar and the father of it
so much of what comes from babylon is
basically lies it's lies and deceit lies
on the seat every single level you
cannot trust anything that comes out of
that mouth
but the whole world is running after the
beast yeah because it looks so
sugar-coated and nice it's presented in
a very nice package
and then the dark the dragon also is
deceptive
and he works in secrecy
so let's just go to the dragon's lies
and the serpent said unto the woman ye
shall not surely die
for god knoweth that in the day that you
eat thereof then your eyes shall be
opened and ye shall be as gods knowing
good and evil so there are the three
lies
of the serpent
there's no death
you will not die
you will be like god
and you in your own capacity will be
able to decide what is good and what is
evil you don't need god to tell you
those are the three lies okay we'll come
back to them
the beast component well revelation 13
tells us who the beast is and i stood
upon the sand of the sea and i saw a
beast rise up out of the sea which is
the waters
so that's amongst the nations
seven heads and ten horns
and upon his head ten crowns and upon
his heads the name of blasphemy so these
are the attributes that we found in
daniel chapter 7 in the little horn
a blasphemous power
and he controls the nations
and the beast which i saw was like unto
a leopard
and his feet were like the feet of a
bear and his mouth like the mouth of a
lion and the dragon gave him his power
and his seat in great authority so the
alliance between the dragon and this
power is rock solid right
and it has all the components
of the prophecy of daniel chapter 7.
so it was like a leopard it had greek
philosophy in it
it was like a bear it had meter persian
and it spoke like a lion babylonian
components in it and the dragon gave him
his power there's only one system that
qualifies martin and all the reformers
said
this was the roman catholic system we're
not talking about people we're talking
about the system
their philosophy is based on greek
philosophy
natural law philosophy greek philosophy
do they believe about the state of the
dead that
god says you will surely die or do they
believe the serpent that you are
immortal they believe the serpent
so we can look at that
so if we go to revelation chapter 17 we
get a little bit more information
and there came one of the seven angels
which had the seven vials so this is
talking about the end time appearance of
this creature because the angel has the
vials of the plague in his hand
so this is just before the end
and he's saying
come heather i will show unto thee the
judgment of the great hall
which sits upon
many waters so i'll show you this
this apostate church
because a in the bible
spiritually speaking
is an apostate
system
so
she sits on many waters she
is
represented in many nations
with whom the kings of the earth have
committed fornication
the inhabitants of the earth have been
made drunk with the wine of a
fornication
so the inhabitants of the earth rather
believe her version
than
god's version yes they swallowed all of
it and the version that she's presenting
is the version of the dragon
right yeah because he's sitting behind
all of it and he's a liar yeah
so it's based on a lie
so he carried me away in spirit into the
wilderness and i saw a woman
that's the church sitting on a scarlet
colored beast
full of names of blasphemy
having seven heads and ten horns
now this scarlet beast
is the same beast with the seven heads
in different forms
that we find in many many places
revelation chapter 11 revelation chapter
12 revelation chapter 13 revelation
chapter 17 and the one that is scarlet
he comes up out of the bottomless pit
so it's demonic force
it's very demonic
and this woman
this church was arrayed in purple and
scarlet color and decked with gold and
precious stones and pearls
and she has a golden cup in her hand
full of the abominations and filthiness
of her fornication
now
sun worship was the great
problem
in the time of israel right
now the only church in the world that
uses the symbol of the woman with a
golden cup in her hand is wrong yeah
there's no other
and the jesuits
they even depict the woman with the
golden cup and the host in the form of a
sun disk coming out with the letters
i-h-s on them
which are the symbols of
the jesuit order and are
baal worship yeah
belzebub worship
so mystery
babylon the great and she is
mystery
secret everything is done in darkness
and behind the scenes correct
and it says on her forehead was the name
written
mystery babylon the great
the mother of harlots and abominations
of the earth so this system has children
and they are also harlots in other words
they are partaking of the same apostasy
that she partakes in because they have
swallowed her doctrines
so who are these daughters now in the
middle ages she had no daughters no she
was the only one she was the only one
and then
protestantism
split from her
it's interesting
at the council of trent
when the archbishop of reggio walked
into the council of the
the dispute whether the bible should be
the standard or whether tradition should
be the standard
and he said to the new people you keep
the sunday
this is a mark of the roman catholic
church a mark of her authority so you
are not following your bible you are
following the teachings of the roman
catholic church
therefore you are just
rebels rebels
and then she says i i sit as queen
my children shall return to me
do they have the economical council
and they're all sitting in that council
together interesting bundle tied
together for the fire and who's the head
still the mother the mother is the head
but interestingly she has her own
organization and she's got all the
children in the economical one but she
pulls the strings and they're returning
to the mother
and i saw this woman drunk with the
blood of the saints and with the blood
of martyrs of jesus when i saw i
wandered with great admiration so martin
she she rides a beast she has political
aspirations but she also is a woman
she has religious aspirations
so let's see what the reformers did with
this this is one of the woodcuts
that they made
the pictures of for martin luther's
bible
and in his bible he depicts the kings of
the world over here
kneeling down in adoration to this beast
with the woman that rides it and on the
woman he's put the triple tiara of the
pope
so what did the reformers say
he writes here there stan all the pope's
bulls and books in which he roars like a
lion and no christian can be saved
without being obedient and subject to
him
in all that he wishes all that he says
all that he does
all of this powerfully demonstrates that
he is the true christ of the end times
or antichrist who has opposed and
exalted himself over christ
and he quotes thessalonians 2
thessalonians 2 verse 4
for he will not permit christians to be
saved depart from his power even though
his power is nothing
neither established nor commanded by god
finally it is nothing but the devil
himself at work when the pope pushes his
lies
about masses purgatory monastic life and
human works and worship
which is in fact the essence of the
papacy over and against god and condemns
kills harassers all christians
who do not exalt and honor this
abomination of his above all things
he had away with words
right quite literally
so he called a spade a shovel
[Laughter]
and then a very interesting story
in this woodcut this is from different
versions of his bible
and
the first one he had the two witnesses
which represent the old and the new
testament right
and these two witnesses
are being confronted by
a dragon beast
and this dragon beast has the triple
crown on its head
so obviously he's saying this is wrong
this is the papal tiara and he is
opposing the two witnesses
and then there was a bit of a
backlash probably from some of the
statesmen of his time
and so when the next edition came out
the same picture was there
the two witnesses and the dragon but
instead of the triple crown
they'd put a normal kingly crown on his
head
they were telling him
don't say it so blunt don't be so blunt
so once luther was convinced that the
roman papacy was the antichrist he
wasted no time making it known in his
writings and using the artist at his
disposal
lukas
to reinforce it visually he had cranach
portray the beast that comes up from the
abbas
with a triple tiered papal tiara to
accompany revelation 11
and in the first edition september 1522
of his translation of the new testament
probably at the complaint of the
imperial council
of regency reich's regiment
the papal tiara had to be replaced in
the second edition december 1522
by a simple crown
so
then it was not so obvious
but martin luther wasn't happy with that
so in the next edition
it came out with the two witnesses again
and the dragon now bigger and uglier and
a little bigger triple crown on his head
making it prominent is making it
prominent
so however when luther's translation of
the entire bible was being prepared for
publication in 1534
and the as yet unidentified mso
manuscript from kranak's workshop was
prepared
preparing woodcuts for it based on large
part of karanak's previous woodcuts
the triple tiered papal tiara was
restored
and christophe walter a proofreader and
typesetter in hans luft's print shop in
wittenberg confirmed that luther wasn't
just responsible for the translation
but also for much of the artwork so
luther made sure
that the triple crown gets put back onto
that dragon in a bigger
more obvious fashion
so this has been a war that's been
raging for a very long time yeah and
like you can see that same war is even
within some of the people that
are talking the same language correct do
we still have that same war raging today
same don't call the pope antichrist no
that's true no no in the economical
movement especially don't do this don't
demonize these
individuals
so now we need to find out who the false
prophet was we know what the dragon was
we know who the beast is now who's the
false prophet
now we remember that she had
children
that had been spawned the only ones that
was born from were the protestant
children right
so in revelation 19 20 it says and the
beast was taken and with him the false
prophet
and then it tells us what this false
prophet portion had done it had wrought
miracles before him with which he
deceived them that had received the mark
of the beast and them that worshipped
his image
so here is a religious system
where miracles play a large role to
convince the people that whatever they
are doing is in harmony with god when
actual fact it's against god's will
right yeah
so this is very interesting
they both were cast alive into the lake
of fire burning with brimstone
this false prophet should have known
better
they had everything at their disposal
plus those woodcuts we just looked on
but they're sitting in an economical
council with them preaching their
doctrines keeping the papal law rather
than christ's law they actually had the
opportunity they did come out yes but
then they went back they went back my
children will return i will not suffer
loss of children she's very arrogant
so the second beast of revelation
chapter 13 is associated with this false
prophet
and the second beast we read about it
from verse 11 and i beheld another beast
coming up out of the earth
and it had two horns like a lamb and he
spoke
as a dragon
now he had two horns now we've we've
seen
that there were many many
and we also saw that were there was a
fallen fallen yes
and here we have two horns the one is
statecraft the other one is churchcroft
and they are
both
speaking like a dragon yes and they're
part of
a lamb correct it looks like a christian
religious entity yes because there's a
lamb that's it
but it speaks like a dragon now we know
who gave power unto the first peace
the dragon
so whatever language that first beast is
speaking is dragon language now the
second one is beginning to speak like a
dragon too this is protestant america
speaking like a dragon
so when they get onto their pulpit these
politicians and these ecclesiastics
they speak the language of the first
piece
and we've shown that over and over in
our lectures
that they are in full harmony and even
sign documents publicly in the vatican
to show that they are in harmony with
the thinking of wrong
and rome
is lying
according to the scriptures that's it
and the second beast exercises all the
power of the first beast now the first
beast was a persecuting power and if you
didn't listen to it
then there were consequences the
inquisition the rack
you name it
so this second one will do the same
thing it will force people how it will
cause the earth
and then which dwell therein to worship
the first beast
whose deadly wound was healed
so how do you do that by making
legislation forcing everyone to comply
to
certain norms and standards which they
make laws
and those are laws which actually belong
to the first piece exactly to rob
and how does he convince the people that
god is apparently on their side
by these
miracles that we've written
correct now we know that's the false
prophet that does the miracle so let's
read it over here
it doeth great wonderth
and he makes fire come down from heaven
on the earth in the sight of men and he
deceiveth them that dwell on the earth
by means of those miracles so there we
have the connection the false prophet is
the one that's performing the miracles
and he's in cahoots with
and he's in cahoots with the first beast
so
martin
when fire comes down from heaven that's
a symbol of the outpouring of the holy
spirit
but the birds are unclean
so this is a false holy spirit leading
people up the garden path to the law and
to the testimony if they speak not
according to this word there's no light
in them
so the protestant churches
with their prosperity gospel and miracle
working gospel
are leading people back to rome
and we've seen kenneth copeland do it
we've seen the great evangelical leaders
do it we've seen rick warren do it we've
seen all of them
taking the people back to rome
so the false prophet fallen
protestantism is in totally harmony with
the system
so the three components are the dragon
spiritism spiritualism
the second one is the beast component
roman catholicism
and the third component is
the false prophet
so in a sense we have a father son and
holy spirit
all power is given unto the son
everybody bows down to rome
and she dictates and all judgment has
been given unto her she will decide what
is right and what is wrong and this
false spirit is running through all of
them and that's what's also giving them
the opportunity to unite correct so
they're not uniting on truth
they're uniting on error
so when we talk about the false prophet
we are talking about
institutionalized false prophetic
movements
the term false prophet may apply to
individuals
but also to institutions so in the days
before protestantism
there was largely only one's false
prophet as institution namely rome
when protestantism split into factions
and manifested the same spirit of
persecution towards those that differed
from them as rome had done
many false prophets arose in fact christ
warned against these false prophets and
we read about it in matthew and in john
and it says many false prophets will
arrive and they will deceive many
we've just heard that the second beast
will deceive right
how many protestant factions are there
in that beast
thousands right
some claim over three thousand
beloved believe not every spirit but try
the spirits whether they're of god
because many false prophets have gone
out into the world so we don't have to
look for individuals we can look for
institutions
all of these thousands of institutions
that preach a gospel of prosperity
and a gospel that the law is no more but
they adhere to the papal law
amazing
jeremiah 51 verse 9 said we would have
healed babylon
but she is not healed forsaker
and let us go everyone into his own
country for her judgment reaches unto
heaven and is lifted up into the skies
so that is the
the warning about typical babylon the
original babylon
it would have healed her
but she cannot be healed
so forsake her come out of her right
flee from her
now when would he have healed her well
right in the beginning
they had the opportunity nebuchadnezzar
yes he accepted the truth exactly
but the very next generations went back
and they went from bad to earth until
many many
tickle
farsen
it was over right so flee from babylon
she will be destroyed the same will
happen to antitypical babylon
revelation 19 20 and the beast was taken
and with him the false prophet
so that's the religious systems in
christianity catholicism and fallen
protestantism
that did the miracles
by which they deceived them that
received the mark of the beast in them
that worshipped his image both were cast
alive into the lake of fire burning with
brimstone
the devil has to wait another thousand
years before he gets destroyed right and
also
this one of revelation also like in
jeremiah
could have been healed it could have
been healed there was a protestant
movement
they had the opportunity they had the
council of strength they had the word of
god
no
they rejected it and placed the
tradition above the word of god
and then they had the audacity
to go and dig up manuscripts out of
waste paper baskets and violate
the original manuscripts and bring out
hundreds of versions which differ
from the received text but is in
accordance with
babylon with their theories correct
so basically what we see in this world
is a clash of worlds matthew 6 verse 10
says thy kingdom come thy will be done
in earth as it is in heaven martin
the will of god is only being done in
heaven at the moment and definitely not
in the earth
so
something must happen
this earth and its rebellion must be
destroyed so that the will of god can be
done in heaven and in earth
mark 3 35 forever shall do the will of
god the same as my brother and my sister
and my mother
so
when it comes to what is the right way
and what is the wrong way
if you do the will of god
then you are part of the family of god
if you do not do the will of god
i don't know you you who practice anomia
against the law of god
ephesians 6 6 not with i service or as
men plead pleasers but as servants of
christ doing the will of god from the
heart
hebrews 10 36 and you have need of
patience that after you have done the
will of god you might receive the
promise so pretty logical can you
receive the promise without doing the
will of god no
so where do you find the will of god
in the law in the law
and you better make sure you read the
right law
so if we go through all of these verses
we don't have to but you can see the
will of god the will of god the will of
god fulfill the royal law says james 2
verse 8 which is the 10 commandments do
this
here are they that keep the commandments
and have the faith of jesus
so the will of god is obviously very
important that's the one side and the
other side is
the opposite of that
so what is the opposite of doing well
well let's read it in second king 17 13
yet the lord testified against israel
and against judah by all the prophets
and by all the seers saying
turn ye from your evil ways
keep my commandments and my statutes
according to the law which i commanded
your fathers and which i sent you by my
servants the prophets so what is evil
going against the law
going against the law so babylon is a
system
that has done away with god's law
idolatry is rampant rome took out the
second commandment which says thou may
not have idols
rome changed the fourth commandment
the sabbath which binds us to god as
creator and redeemer and bonded to
herself
and changed it to the sun there so
babylon is fallen we've read it many
times and she has become a house of
demons i think we should
understand that by now
so let's take a statement from the great
controversy it reads this scripture
points forward to a time
when the announcement of the fall of
babylon as made by the second angel of
revelation
14 8 of revelation 14 is to be repeated
with the additional mention of the
corruptions which have been entering the
various organizations that constitute
babylon
since that message was first given in
the summer of 1844
a terrible condition of the religious
world is here described with every
rejection of truth the minds of the
people will become darker their hearts
more stubborn
until they are entrenched in an infidel
hardy hood
in defiance of the warnings which god
has given they will continue to trample
upon one of the precepts of the
decalogue until they are led to
persecute those who hold it sacred
christ is set at naught
in the contempt placed upon his word and
his people
as the teachings of spiritualism
are accepted by the churches there's the
dragon
component the restraint imposed upon the
carnal heart is removed
and the profession of religion will
become a cloak to conceal the basis
iniquity
a belief in spiritual manifestations
opens the door to seducing spirits and
doctrines of devil
and thus the influence of evil angels
will be felt in the churches
it's amazing
the jesuits even say that we can use the
science revealed by demons by the devil
himself
obviously in seances and other
manifestations so they are working
together with these manifestations
and that false spirit
also came in and now it's like we
just read
perceived to be
the good one correct now just to make
absolutely sure
that we are not
being judgmental here
we have to find the doctrines of the
serpent
and the lies of the serpent within the
system yes so let's go there
genesis chapter 3 verse 1 and he said
unto the woman yea has god said
immediately it caused
doubt and what did he say you will
surely not die
what does rome teach
this is the catechism of the catholic
church the church teaches that every
spiritual soul is immortal it does not
perish when it separates from the body
at death
who do they believe the serpent or god
the serpent they believe the serpent are
they perhaps just deceived or do they
know
that god said something else
let's go there new catholic encyclopedia
on the immortality
the soul in the old testament means not
a part of man but the whole man as the
living being
similarly in the new testament it
signifies human life the life of the
individual conscious object
recent exegetes have maintained that the
new testament does not teach the
immortality of the soul in the
hellenistic sense of survival of an
immortal principle of the death so they
know
the bible doesn't teach it
but we teach it in direct contradiction
to god that's spiritualism that's
doctrine of the dragon
so
in defiance of god's word they say we
believe the serpent
their official doctrine
directly
now it's interesting that both luther
and tyndall espoused the doctrine of
self-sleep
in other words that the dead know
nothing that there will be a
resurrection either unto life or unto
eternal death oblivion
you will die if you sin you will die you
won't have an intermediate state where
you can play poker and have parties in a
place which they
glorify as hell
what about the second lie you shall be
as gods
here's the roman catholic catechism and
it says that the
word became flesh to make us partakers
of the divine nature
for this is why the word became man and
the son of god became the son of man so
that man by entering into communion with
the word
and thus receiving divine sonship might
become a son of god
for the son of god became man so that we
might become god
martin that's amazing right
that's new age
yes the only begotten son of god wanting
to make us share us in his divinity
assumed our nature so that he made man
might make men gods
doctrine of the serpent doctrine of the
serpent presumption of the highest order
official teaching of the roman catholic
church so if i sit at meal with her
and say that i'm one with you in your
purpose
then i'm sinning against god
right yeah
so papal claims to divinity besides the
numerous medieval papal claims to being
god on earth modern popes have not
distanced themselves from such claims
and pope leo
said about the papacy our thoughts went
out towards the immense multitude of
those who are strangers to the gladness
that fold the catholic hearts some
because they lie in absolute ignorance
of the gospel others because they
descend from the catholic belief though
they bear the name of christians this
thought has been an easy sort of deep
concern to us
capitalized
god said let us make man in our image
this is arrogance martin
it is impossible to think of such a
large portion of mankind deviating as it
were from the right part
as they move away from us
there's another god the great the little
horn will speak blasphemy now that's
speaking blasphemous correct and not
experience a sentiment of innermost
grief but since we hold upon the earth
the place of god almighty this is so
blatantly arrogant
and seeing that they are infallible can
never be retracted right yeah
so what about the third claim good and
evil catechism of the catholic church
article 3 man's freedom
god created man a rational being
conferring on him the dignity of a
person who can initiate and control his
own actions
god will that man should be left in the
hand of his own counsel so that he might
of his own accord seek his creator and
freely attain his full and blessed
perfection by cleaving to him is this
biblical
no bible says nobody seeks god no not
one not one this is the reason
why their world is in a state that it is
if only you have
listen to my command
your peace would have been
like a river
so who prescribes what's right or wrong
man or god
according to them man according to them
man this is the serpent's doctrine this
is the doctrine of the devil yeah and if
you sit in harmony with the system
you are sinning
you become a partaker come out of her my
people yes
so since vatican ii a significant broad
consensus on moral
theological literature suggests now
let's just define who's speaking here
richard m
reason informed by faith is a jesuit
professor
of theology right
now this is their catholic doctrine it's
doctrine of the serpent
the human person is the most appropriate
point of departure for elaborating on
the meaning of morality in general
and for providing the fundamental
criteria which are necessary for dealing
with specific moral questions
to say that the person adequately
considered is the norm of morality does
not dethrone god and raise the human
person to the level of supreme value
but it certainly does
because you're saying man is the point
of departure we don't have to listen to
god exactly it doesn't dethrone god but
it just leaves him up there
right yeah it sidesteps him because you
will know
best between good and evil correct
the great advantage of having an
institutionalized authority in the
magisterium the hierarchy of the church
is that it provides a structure which
can bring together in a cooperative and
complementary way the experience and
insights of various perspectives
so as to reach as complete an expression
of truth about moral life as possible so
where do you get your moral values from
by consensus
and from
the top leaders correct so if you have a
bunch of perverts in your group
then your moral perspective and your
moral
benchmark will be pretty low
and if we look at the atrocities
that have been
practiced by this institution
and the lord has made sure
that even the news media
tells us of the pedophilia and the
disgusting activities that take place in
these institutions if that is the moral
compass whereby we judge morality then
god help us
moreover in the midst of so many
conflicting voices telling us what to do
and so many diverse communities
projecting images of what makes life
worthwhile
we are fortunate to have the magisterium
to teach in moral matters
martin i can just say to that we are
fortunate to have god's word to teach us
in moral matters
unbelievable the primary responsibility
of the magisterium
is to help us to understand the gospel
for our time
and to foster our assimilation of its
basic value
now wonder we have legislation that is
so perverse these days
totally contradicts the word of god and
presumes it to be righteousness yeah
because it fits in with our time correct
so the formula no infallible decision
conscious decides is a complete
distortion of the real function of
conscience
conscience needs to be informed
for catholics to make a decision of
conscience with indifference to or in
spite of the magisterium would be
forfeiting one's claim
to be acting as a loyal catholic and
according to a properly informed
conscience now we just had a talk on
liberty we spoke about conscience
where's your conscience come from martin
from that book
from this book let's pick it up let's
make sure people see this book this book
from there we get
the information as to how our conscience
should be informed
these people say no yeah they say you're
not even a catholic if you don't listen
to them correct and that also
applies to all the other denominations
that are now sitting in ecumenical
councils with this
correct system setting aside
basic doctrines of the bible
for the sake of harmony can two walk
together unless they agree no and how is
your conscience going to be
affected if you do this it's
unbelievable
now in 2018
so people will say well that was the
papacy of the middle ages right no this
is the paper seed
of all ages
the authority of the pope part one he
has a catholic answers where they're
asked this question
in other catholic tracts and answers we
have shown that the church fathers
recognized that jesus made peter the
rock
on which
he would build his church that this gave
peter a special primacy that peter went
to rome and that he left his successors
there and then i'm just going to read
the highlighted portion because of its
superior origin all churches must agree
with rome
this is an arrogance it comes from their
own
sources and all
are at this stage agreeing
as far as
i'm concerned there is my standard
and their standard and their norm they
can
preach as much greek philosophy as they
like but it's not biblical
and then to be so arrogant as to
enthrone yourself upon a great white
throne between two cherubs with four
living creatures surrounding you
is a blasphemy which is unbelievable
and uh
the present pope has done this on a
number of occasions
so he is just as guilty as his
predecessors because god in the bible is
pictured
as sitting like that so is the system
babylon yes
okay
let's just make sure again let's let's
ask the jesuits to elaborate
so how does this influence the use of
scripture
according to rome
so the catholic moral tradition has laid
claim to two sources for acquiring moral
knowledge scripture and natural law
natural laws greek greek philosophy
because it has been so concerned with
finding a common ground for moral life
which all peoples could endorse catholic
tradition
has given prominence to natural law as
the primary source of moral knowledge
blatantly putting aside the scriptures
while it gives the appearance of a
biblical grounding
this is really arrogant
while it gives the appearance of a
biblical grounding to moral theology
proof texting really does not allow
scripture
to enter the fabric of moral theological
reflection
martin if you read that
get out of her my people that you be not
partakers of a sin this
system is going to go to perdition to
the lake of fire if you want to be tied
up in a bundle with it then be sure they
will end up in a lake of fire
because of their being subject to
historical conditioning biblical texts
must be interpreted in order to be
applied to contemporary situations
so rewrite the bible as it suits you you
know and this sounds in a lot of
different denominations already all the
time we hear it we have to hire critics
we have to apply the bible to our time
whether it comes to the question of
abortion whether it comes to the
question of homosexuality whether it
comes to the question of gender no
matter what we talk about you have to
reinterpret the bible no you read your
bible as it stands and you bring
yourself up to that standard and not the
bible down to your pathetic standard
martin i must calm down i'm getting a
little bit hot under the collar
when i read about this babylonian
atrocity over here
martin this is an amazing little book
and it comes from 1946
moody press the bible and the roman
church that's not so long ago 1946
well it's before your time
a little bit a little bit before i think
for your time as well
well
by three
years i was almost there but listen to
what these people wrote in those days
oh
my heart longs for
theologians and preachers that will
still preach the word of god i want my
church back
the reformers regarded the holy
scripture as the soul rule of faith and
practice
and the sons of the reformers
throw that soul rule out of the window
torn to shreds by the death
impious hands of the critic
with the bible goes the god of the bible
and when we charge rome with a literal
idolatry for a veneration of images
relics and so forth she comes back with
an accusation of intellectual idolatry
in that protestantism
having rejected the god of revelation
has created a new god
the product of apostate thinking
rome is not afraid of modernism
it is a fruitful fishing pool
because the human heart cannot be
satisfied with the vague vaporous
uncertainties of modernism
rome addresses herself to those who are
under the influence of that emasculated
brand of protestantism
and offers the authority of the church
founded by jesus christ in place of the
bewildering uncertainties of
indifferentism
it is so beautifully put
you know some people will say
the language is too complicated well
study
read it again read it again until you
understand what they are saying you know
i wonder what this person would have
wrote if he was alive today
maybe it would have been so
indoctrinated that he'd sit in an
economical council and not write
anything anymore but at least
his brain wasn't tied behind his back
this was protestantism
1946 martin
what do they teach on the atonement the
most
sublime
heart of the gospel
isaiah therefore i will divide him a
portion with the great and he shall
divide the spoil with the strong because
he has poured out his soul unto death
and he was numbered with the
transgressors and he bear the sin of
many
and made intercession for the
transgressors
and the scripture was fulfilled which
says
and he was numbered with the
transgressors so there you have the old
testament and you have the fulfillment
in the new testament and this is the
heart of the plan of salvation the
atonement
and rome says no there's no atonement
jesus didn't die for you you're not
saved by the blood of the lamb
that's babylonian you are saved by your
works
so one of the works is sunday observant
the apostolic letter ds domini of the
holy father john paul ii to the bishops
clergy and faithful
will only read this blue portion
pope leo
the 13th in his encyclical
nuvarum
spoke of sunday rest as the workers
right which the state must guarantee
so here we come finally to the crux of
the mat
here you have a law
which is a roman catholic law
and this pope leo in his encyclical
rerun of
which deals with the social economic
order
says that the state
should enforce and guarantee sunday
sacredness
you see here you get to the like you
said the crux yes because here
the authority of god
comes in
contrast with the authority of the
serpent
absolutely
so you have two
contrasting
authoritative statements remember the
sabbath to keep it holy why because i'm
your creator i'm your redeemer and that
is why i said this is the day the
seventh day here comes rome and says no
the first day of the week
and we will do it my way and the state
must guarantee it so when the state
guarantees
this
then it is doing the bidding of the
first beast
and it is enforcing its mark of
ecclesiastical power and therefore it is
not the question of the day
it's a question of authority which
happens to be linked to a day
so let's just make sure because martin
we have to understand who babylon is and
why people must separate from it yes and
a lot of people are
confused about this mark of this beast
correct
so let's go a little bit deeper
this is the catechism explained
this is bellamine forum
edition
now
bellamine was a cardinal but
this is the catechism explained
and it talks about
the commandments of rome and it talks
about six commandments of the church
now these commandments of the church
have got nothing to do with the ten
commandments it's an explanation of one
commandment
namely the sabbath commandment so let's
read of it
the six precepts of the church are an
amplification of the third commandment
of the decalogue
now we must remember that they removed
the second one
so the third one should actually be the
fourth one so this is the sabbath
commandment which is the fourth one in
the bible but they've made it the third
one because in their arrogance they have
removed the second one so that they can
practice idolatry and worship pachamama
if they want to
the first precept of the church notice
again
doesn't say the bible the first precept
of the church enjoins upon the faithful
to rest from work on certain days
besides the sunday
to give thanks to god for special graces
the second precept of the church ordains
the manner in which sunday
and other holy days of obligation are to
be observed
the third and fourth precepts of the
church oblige us to confess and
communicate at least once a year
i thought the bible says we must die
daily martin
once a year's enough we don't have to
worry about that
the fifth precept bids us to support our
pastors
and the sixth forbids us to marry
non-catholics or to solemnize marriage
at forbidden times
so these are rules pertaining to their
authority to proclaim feast days
then it says we are under a rigorous
obligation to keep the commandments of
the church
not the commandments of god
for disobedience to the church is
disobedience to christ now this must be
another christ
because jesus said i have not come to
abolish the law i've come to fulfill it
not one jot or one tittle will by any
means disappear from the law right
so christ has conferred upon the church
the same powers which he himself
received from his father
he said to his apostles that the father
sent me i also send you
when the church enjoins anything upon us
it is the same as if christ enjoined it
for he said
whatsoever you shall bind upon earth
shall be bound also in heaven in
disobeying the church we disobey christ
but they forget that christ also said
that you cannot change the law
in vain they worshipped me teaching for
doctrine the commandments of men right
as he told the apostle he that despises
you despises me
our lord speaks of the church as a
kingdom
he also compares it to a fold to teach
us that the children of the church must
obey their ecclesiastical superiors
this is arrogance of the highest order
and that one pulls through to basically
all denominations that's why they had to
change that verse in the bible too right
every society is authorized to make laws
which the members must observe this the
church does and by her mouth god makes
his will known to us he therefore who
wantonly violates one of the churches
laws commits a grievous sin
and the bible says he who violates one
of god's commandments he's guilty of
them all so we have two wills here
martin two worlds
this catechism continues the rulers of
the church
are empowered to dispense the faithful
from the observance of any of the
commandments of the church for weighty
reasons
now that is amazing so the church can
make null and void its law
whereas god's law is eternal not one jot
or one tittle will ever be removed from
the law so if they want you to sin
they can
make a null and void yes you want to
have a party get an indulgence yeah get
paid pay it forward yes
like that one who came
to tesla and said i want an indulgence
because i want to commit a crime so i
gave it to him
and then he
he
attacked him when he was going through
the jungle or the forest with all the
money that he'd collected from
indulgences he robbed him
of that money so they took him to court
and he he showed his indulgence he said
but tetzl gave me
okay i could
i've got to get out of jail free god
absolutely and the judge threw the
thing out of the court this is so
ridiculous it's unbelievable
and this is a catechism explained
so
let's just reiterate the first
commandment of the church
in other words the most important
commandment in the church
is the observance of sundays and holy
days
people don't
realize that this is the crux of the
matter they think it's just a day it
can't be that important
bringing it back to authority that's why
they put it there
in the first commandment of the church
the solemn observance of holy days is
enjoined upon us there are seven
festivals of our lord five of our lady
and three of the saints
so here's a question
in catholic christian instructed
has the catholic church power to make
any alterations in the commandments of
god answer
instead of the seventh day
and other festivals appointed by the old
law the church has prescribed the
sundays
and holy days to be set apart for god's
worship and these we are now obliged to
keep
in consequence of god's commandment
instead of the ancient sabbath so she
claims that she did it this is a crime
against god
a crime which is being perpetuated to
this day
and is even ensconced in lodatusi
he writes in ludatusi this is pope
francis international negotiations
cannot make significant progress due to
positions taken by countries
which place their national interests
above the global common good
so the kings of the world will have to
give their power unto the beast they
cannot be autonomous they have to do
what rome says that's what he's saying
that's what
what revelation predicts will happen
right and we will see
it's already happening
correct
then he writes there quite clearly in
his
in his encyclical the universe unfolds
in god who fills it completely
hence there is a mystical meaning to be
found in a leaf in a mountain trail in a
dew drop in a poor person's face you
must discover god in all things so he's
preaching a pantheistic god
and not a personal
god
so he's welcome to his god but that one
is not going to be my god
and then he hammers the sunday question
on sunday our participation in the
eucharist has special importance
sunday like the jewish sabbath is meant
to be a day which heals our relationship
with god with ourselves with others and
with the world it also proclaims man's
eternal resting god excuse me
that's in direct contradiction to the
word of god
so here we have all of these elements in
modern babylon
and the churches including the
protestant churches
are in line so we find the independent
catholic news saying
let's keep a jubilee for the earth lauda
to see week and they talk about
sunday
creation sunday
firstly here in a year then on a regular
basis
the lutheran world federation does
exactly the same thing
also a jubilee a rest for the earth
and the sunday alliance says
the right to disconnect and the need for
a european weekly common day of rest
invitation to the european sunday
alliance webinar
2021 so they want all you
eu citizens to be subject to sunday
whose law is that martin rome
it's the mark of the beast
how prominent
does the world consider rome
and particularly the second beast of
revelation that lamb like beast with
this two two owns correct now here is
john kerry
and as we know he's a member of skull
and bones
so
chapter 3 2 2
of the illuminati which was founded by
adam weishaupt who was a jesuit
and
they say that he was a jesuit that had
become
apostate but no he was just
a jesuit that had become a jesuit with a
short robe
and was doing the work in the
clandestine fashion he just went
undercover so you have the secret
society the dragon religion and you have
the kings of the world you have the
second beast then how does he consider
the morality of the first beast let's
look at it
you're on a very important uh mission
here to europe can you tell us why is it
important to include a visit with the
pope
during your visit to europe to talk
about climate change
well the pope is one of the great voices
of reason and compelling moral authority
on the subject of the climate crisis
he's been ahead of the curve he's been a
leader
his encyclical la dato c is really very
very powerful document
uh eloquent and morally very persuasive
and i think that
his voice will be a very important voice
leading up to and through the glasgow
conference
how can the united states as a
superpower
and the hoist see as a much smaller
country but nonetheless his moral and
spiritual authority
collaborate in the fight against climate
change
well the holy father is one of if not
the
one of the most powerful voices on the
planet and he's been
extraordinary in the eloquence of his
uh
call on people to to to step up and be
reasonable and to
live out our responsibility as human
beings and caring for god's creation
um and and we all have to be stewards of
that creation that's his message
but because he is above politics and
outside of the hurley burley of
day-to-day
national
conflict etc
i think he can
sort of
you know shake people a little bit and
bring them to the table with a better
sense of our common obligation
and i think the holy father speaks with
special authority to our sense of
obligation to each other
and the ways in which
we need to all step up now together
given the divisions of the world and
some of the polarization and
the ideology and conflict
that voice is more important than ever
now you know what martin nothing is by
chance this interview where did it take
place in a room under which
picture pope francis yes
there's this big picture of pope francis
and he is
elevating him
and lifting him up in the basket as the
standard of morality yeah he says he's
the yeah the standard of morality
correct
so pope warns against elitism cruelty
and extreme individualism you may not be
an individual you must listen to the
magisterium so if you decide for the
bible you're in big trouble
so the principle of common good in the
catholic church and social doctrine
everyone also has the right to enjoy
conditions of social life that are
brought about by the quest for the
common good
so the distribution of created goods etc
this common good is defined by the
papacy
every nation and every individual
must be subject to it
so the pope calls on
nations to work towards a global coming
common good
the nation-state is no longer able to
procure the common good of its
population alone
the common good has become global and
nations must associate for their own
benefit
is this a fulfillment of prophecy
and with those words he actually
acknowledges that everybody is on board
already correct so the kings of the
world have they given their power unto
the beast yes unfortunately so let's
just listen to what the jesuits have to
say this is the beast from the
bottomless pit
opening its mouth and it says the common
goods conceptual roots lie
in greek and roman philosophy as the
goal of political life the good of the
city martin this is very important
because we all know
that this is the city babylon
and the tasks entrusted to civil leaders
now if it's based on greek and roman
is that biblical no but it does qualify
them for the biblical explanation of
that beast correct because it has the
body of a leopard
and it has the components of rome in it
so this is exactly what babylon is all
about and we have to decide where our
moral morality and our duty as entrusted
to civic leaders comes from
so many civic leaders tell us to do
things contrary to our conscience
and in harmony with this babylonian
system
there comes a time when you will have to
say i have to obey god more than man
right
now here's another one promoting
religious freedom you know they always
talk about religious freedom and so many
people say but rome is for religious
freedom
i mean i've heard people from
our own ranks say rome is changed it's
for religious freedom so let's listen to
her definition
of of religious freedom
we hope
that by showing people what our
religious freedom permits us to do
to serve the common good our religious
liberties will be respected
so only if you follow us in our greek
and roman philosophy will we allow you
freedom to be what you are
but if you follow the bible
then you are not following the common
good and you become an enemy yeah so
you're free as long as you do what we
tell you to correct so let's just make
sure religious liberty
ought never to be collapsed into freedom
of worship because our relationship with
god extends beyond
worship martin that is so blasphemous
that it boggles the mind that someone
has the arrogance and the audacity to
pin something like that ridiculous you
know it's
like saying with meditation you want to
go beyond
what the bible teaches correct we will
tell you what you must do forget about
this book
so martin this is a very blasphemous
system and the only solution if you want
to save yourself is come out of her my
people
let's just make sure how these people
think let's ask another jesuit paul
netter
to tell us how he perceives
religion
for jesus
the spiritual prophet
that's enough to make you nauseous
already right
the focus of his life and relationships
was the reign of god
that meant he was not as his followers
have often been church centered
his primary concern was not to increase
membership of his own movement or
community rather it was to transform
people's hearts
so as to transform their society
my kingdom is not of this world he
didn't come to change the world he came
to call people out of the world this is
the opposite of the gospel
that's it he write that's the crux of
the problem christian dualism has so
exaggerated the difference between god
and the world
that it cannot really show how the two
form a unity
martin
the bible says quite clearly in james 4
ye adulterers and adulteresses know ye
not that friendship with the world is
enmity with god
whosoever therefore will be a friend of
the world isn't the enemy of god and
this man says that they're one and the
same
it's so distorting this also love your
neighbor thing because
loving your neighbor according to the
bible is also
trying to save him
jesuit thinking
and i would like to remind people that
the present pope is a jesuit
jesuit thinking is from the bottomless
pit
it is a negation of the word of god
it is an elevation of the word of the
serpent
it is
satanic
when the bible says babylon has fallen
in power unto the beast revelation 13
verse 4 they worshipped the dragon which
gave power unto the beast and they
worshiped the beast saying was like unto
the beast who is able to make war with
him
and ex this is now the first beast so
when you obey its dictates you're
actually worshiping the dragon you're
not worshiping christ
and the second beast and he exercises
all the power of the first beast before
him and causes the earth and them that
dwell there in to worship the first
beast whose deadly wound was healed
is this power of church and state
dictating papal morality to the world
yes
all the kings and all the merchants
everybody
this is the fulfillment of prophecy
so here's the journal america this is
the jesuit review it's the jesuit
journal pope francis and forty faith
leave this call urgent action to combat
climate change
future generations will never forgive us
so when they talk about climate change
they have a hidden agenda yes
definitely have a hidden agenda if he's
encyclical on the environment
tells you
one of its main things is we have to
keep sunday holy
then obviously it has to be incorporated
into the plan that they have correct so
again they're working in an underhand
way
and here is the article from earthbeat
102 faith leaders rally 400 clean energy
as key cog in biden's job plan
now we don't have to read everything
here it's just interesting that 3 000
faith leaders and 100 pastors professors
and evangelical leaders are all on board
with the same agenda yes so the false
prophets
have joined
with so the false prophet is part of
babylon
and they're proclaiming a
message in unity
and they will be destroyed
and if you don't want to be destroyed
with them what must you do come out you
must come up
pope francis joins with ceos of fortune
500 companies to form a new council
focused on creating a more equitable
economy martin
is the economy associated with the
system yep
will the economic power be used
used to force your will yes yes you
won't be able to work for them you won't
be able to buy you won't be able to sell
so the whole package has come together
then biden went to meet the pope
just before the cop 26.
martin and then you have pope francis
encourages teen climate actress green
greater thunder to continue her fight
here you have a young woman who tells
children not to go to school to boycott
to riot to pick it
uh is is this in harmony with god's way
of doing things no
so whenever i look at it i see this pope
and i see the world leaders and i see
the churches
marching
according to his tune but he's tuned
it's not in harmony
with the music of the bible
and even the lord warned us
i'll put children in charge of you
correct correct
now
we also know that the dragon has secret
components right and he works in secrecy
mystery and god has done nothing in
secret
so why do they depict this young girl
always with closing one eye
because this is an occult message
so the pope works with secret societies
there's no doubt about it because john
kerry
is one of his uh you know
main allies and he belongs to skull and
bones so what do you expect they work
with secret societies they work through
freemasonry they are the masters of
freemasonry the jesuits have freemasonry
worshipping their ihs
baal worship
is this a pure chance picture or is this
a signal picture
the guardian right
so we must also recognize the dragon
in terms of the secret societies and how
they work to get all the politicians on
board and all of those things you cannot
split this it is such an important part
of them
that you have to put it out there that
people can realize this correct and if
you go to the spirit of prophecy you
read this amazing statement
that all need wisdom carefully to search
out the mystery of iniquity that figures
so largely
in the winding up of this earth's
history god's presentation of the
detestable works of the inhabitants of
the ruling powers of the world who bind
themselves into secret societies and
confederacies
not honoring the law of god
so we know that secret societies are
also working behind the scenes to bring
about the events portrayed in the bible
there is not a politician
let's not be quite that drastic there is
hardly a politician
that is not in some way roped especially
if he's high up
roped into this kind of alliance
genesis 6 5 7 god saw that the
wickedness of man was great in the earth
and that every imagination of the
thoughts of his heart
was only continually evil
so this is what we have martin
that was in the days of noah and it said
that as in the days of noah it will be
correct
so if we go to these secret societies we
don't have time to do electoral and
secret societies
but if you go to the encyclopedia.com
you'll see that the united nations
organizations are based on occultism
they're not based on scripture
an organization founded in 1932 to apply
the teachings of former theosophist
alice a bailly
in the social context specifically to
improve human relations in the world
she founded the arcane school to
propagate the theosophical teachings
that came through her channelings from
the tibetan master
this is something strictly forbidden by
god this is spiritism of the highest
order
and the organization supports the work
of the united nations and is an
officially recognized and accredited
non-governmental organization they're
working with the devil directly
and the theosophical society
was lucifer trust
which then became lucis trust
so its activities had been the formation
of triangles linkage of individuals who
employ constructive thought in a daily
meditation of groups of three
visualization great invocations this is
occultism in of the highest order
and this is part of the babylonian
system it works in secret
so just for clarity's sake let's show
that little video
again to show how the politicians the
religious leaders and the media and all
of the entertainment world basically is
part of the system
babylon is a huge component
come out of my people
and this is the sign of the master of
the second veil
see
purely masonic
[Music]
you don't pick this stuff up off the
street
now this is how it's generally executed
in the public arena
[Music]
so when you see this
or this
you know for certain where it comes from
and who they belong to
look at krema on the front page of the
privately circulated freemason magazine
officially a mason like fellow brother
tony abbott
and he's doing this
[Music]
martin if we can start wrapping it up i
don't think we have to say anything
about
what the people just saw we've shown it
before but for the sake of completeness
to have it in one package we've put it
into this presentation as well
in first timothy 4 16 we read take heed
unto the self and unto the doctrine
continuing them for in doing this thou
shalt save thyself and them that hear
thee
don't get sidelined by the teachings of
the serpent
second peter 1 verse 19 says we have
also a
more sure word of prophecy
we unto you do well that you take heed
as unto a light that shineth in a dark
place until the day dawn and the day
star arise in your heart don't ignore
the bible don't listen to what comes out
of the mouth of babylon separate
yourself from them
and that is why revelation 18 verse 4
comes down to our time and reaches
basically the fullness
of ripeness
in our time and i heard another voice
from heaven saying
come out of her my people
so if you are in any system martin
that is associated with babylon either
through economical councils or through
secret societies or through political
affiliations
or through the teachings that you sit in
your denomination because they're
affiliated with them then come up
that you be not partakers of a sins and
that you receive not of her plagues
and with joshua 24 15 we want to say
and if it seems evil unto you to serve
the lord choose thee this day who you
will serve god don't force you no
whether the gods of your father served
that were on the other side of the flood
or the gods of the amorites in whose
land you dwell
but as for me in my house we will serve
the lord
this is the final decision for humanity
you're either with the system or you're
against the system there's no halfway
measure
may god give us all the wisdom
to choose
god's way
of a man's way let's pray
heavenly father babylon has fallen
and i hope through this presentation
that it has been made abundantly clear
that she has been fallen in a long
a long time already
but in particularly in the time that we
are living in
she's coming together in this
terrible triune union
and she will prescribe
her dictates and her dogmas and a wine
for all humanity to drink
help us to separate ourselves from the
system
that we be not partakers of her plagues
and do not perish in her sins in jesus
name i pray amen amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe
click here
when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here
thank you